what's your name Habib javi
your Habib are you related to hubby my
name is Xavier
[Music]
assalamualaikum
right on the main
tickler
three beautiful mustard
palma de se passe timo vdj in avg
several inca gavage soffit the monopod
originate switch-mode a dog Adana
the sefirot emo quarterly swiss fiato
Allahu Allah
now on negotiate inshallah Salaam
alaikum
is the main presidential building
[Music]
even got one of these years Mickey D's
stay away if you want to have good
health stay away
Dean came to save us from the fire look
welcome to boss now Sarajevo
[Music]
I wish for channel what's your name
[Music]
yeah house cool it's quite good
[Music]
we found there was right there so what
unique thing have you done today we
bought some extra liver now we're
looking to give it to a cat or in this
case a dog see even
in Islam the sanctity of life is so so
important in this case animals not all
human beings so charities considered
charity even feeding an animal in Aslam
now we got new friends
it's not a college
they haven't got the latest but one that
smoking kills causes cancer g'nite
Islamic University here the one thing
you know the problem some said if we see
an evil changing with your hands your
mouth speak out against it or worse is
to hate it what you're in your heart but
one of the things we see a lot is here
is the students of the Islamic
University smoking cigarettes so his
basic thick and everybody knows those of
any Islamic authority that you know they
had in the old days when they didn't
have all the science and they didn't
know the harms that came from cigarettes
then it was labeled makrooh but now that
we know it's hundred-percent
substantiated that smoking causes cancer
and cancer and this can lead to death so
I lost want Allah tells us not to throw
ourselves into destruction not to kill
ourselves not to waste our money so it's
basic fix basic Islamic knowledge
nowadays that smoking in Saddam so I
thought I'd just share this with because
probably a minute maybe a lot of our
brothers who are still smoking here they
don't know but inshallah this is out of
the love if you get this do some basic
research and you come to know it's not
mokuba's Haram so this is my way of
implementing the hadith that I just
shared with you and that's with
compassion I love our brothers here cuz
we saw some many smoking thank you smell
like this is it really extremely
important because it's a foundation that
builds on on other things also
now with this part things this is
because it was an issue that just came
up but these are the future leaders
of the community so if the leaders are
not intact and how do we expect the
followers to be in text so we as people
as the leaders have to be striving for
being at a higher level of following the
Quran and the Sunnah of our beloved
Prophet SAW song and looking to stay
away from all things that are prohibited
to the best of our ability and if you're
going to do something if you have an
addiction do it in private until you can
overcome that addiction because you
don't want the young kids they're gonna
follow you too
so you have the young ones who are
saying well if their mom is smoking then
I'm gonna smoke you must be allowed no
this prohibited in our Deen and
everything anything remember anything
that's Haram means it's harmful for you
don't look at it is something that like
it it's a restriction on you it's just
that I don't of law Allah has mercy the
things that aren't Haram it's harmful
for you so look at it like that it's
there to save your life and your soul so
I would suggest anybody who is who's
addicted to the cigarettes even those
those shisho machines that stuff also
causes cancer it's very bad for your
health do the research make the NIA the
intention make dawah to a lost one
thought to the Creator to help you
overcome this he will and do your best
to strive to give this up and you give
it up for Allah for the crater for the
Almighty believe me he'll replace it
with something better you get them a
tremendous reward but if you set a bad
trend and someone start smoking or doing
this stuff to heat shisha these things
because of you you help them because
they see you and I think it's cool now
they think it's all right you're gonna
carry this in you're gonna carry that in
did they say so let's get away from
starting bad trends let's wreck the fire
fairs and start setting the good trends
so we can get the good rewards the edges
from setting the good standards
especially for our youth out there who
are paying attention to the leaders we
want to be good leaders and show me
what's your name
happy happy your Habib are you related
to hobby
my name is happy you know hobby yeah you
know the Habib
no no fighter cubby you know you know
it's the only man don't know your name
your name is ha ha beep Bobby yeah but
you know my brother hubby our brother
huh be the UFC fighter of course so this
is a way I understand it now now you
understand yeah so were you from from
Ghana qivana you Muslim Salam alaikum
Salam how long you been in the mansion
how you like Sarah yeah you know I was
here for Ramadan I make all Ramadan in
Bosnia here yeah and this is perfect for
me you here vacation or you working
application I live in Germany with my
funny oh very nice nice to meet you go
thanks is like a setup
that's a game show thanks so much this
is really helpful
this man has a desert is one young man
more young younger than many young
people here in Surrey were also in
America
he's young in his heart why he's young
he is young because he believed in Allah
Masha Allah
I'm very young with lot of mileages and
this is the similar case we are like one
a problem that when you cut him if thank
you it means my heart I love him just
say
[Laughter]
Mimi Wallace nothing Queenie on
furniture only mine I that sugar denise
austin your solution here
give me two bullets near Eubank
carjacked watch the digits the to balan
about this estimate the recently salami
bill finish serving over the service
agreement
probably the superior there's the
separate process a sunnah teeth with us
before the frecchi dango very cars at
rochester be more enriched in the module
gives the president today the streets
commerce to ignite Romanian doctor
did I said be on the doctor is fully
doctor medicine
maritza depressed that case this fiscal
mess memory tests miss Commerce Runa
Yahoo nazar chatter t done is a jacquard
Bradshaw circuit lever arm Rachel's
party would see Oh Simba name on the
admission request did not you Genesis
Google s pinkish or cream peddlers and
develop Debbie put a super give a
generous appropriate when approaching
the Divas team apart
you can torture the sympathy
but you pull up with a fantasy
the goal German is to steal them that's
a senator Roger Kadena nice teen on an
energy audit made okay family TV kappa
sonic souvenir zero two newest
initiative destruction if you eat like a
pig you look like a pig and you sound
like oh three ways to go
don't eat like a pig
don't behave like a and Anja ho ho ho
[Music]
come to prayer come to prayer come to
success come to success but it started
with God is the greatest God is the
greatest
there's no nothing worthy of worship
except the Creator God Allah then it
says I bear witness that there is
nothing where they worship who said the
crater I bear witness that Muhammad is
the Messenger of God come to prayer come
to success
Allah hope that God is the greatest God
is the greatest
what zinc yeah where you guys from Italy
need to leave it beautifully and today
the Mafia beats a mandelino can Angelo
near the ravine see see look
misconception see Italian right away -
mafia see Muslim terrorists it's all
baloney yeah yeah yeah yeah stability
yeah the world is the same Muslims are
some of the most peaceful people on the
planet
not every Italian is Mafia we watched
too much Goodfellas and Godfather the
crime you know
[Music]
wonderful movie better story for
attenion yes we check out the show we're
gonna go pray nice meeting you
I'm sorry perilous
let me a consoling them all day it's
Jerry wife like it god bless you God
with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]